[Music]
this is where the shooting took place
now I just turned 15 so I was like super
young you know what I mean I'm still
super young and it's like ridiculous
that I've had to go through some of the
stuff I've had to go through but I know
that this is not it came like you know
like like people really died like from
gun violence every single day like in
this neighborhood
[Music]
when your friend of Chicago you turn the
news and you see gun violence somebody
shot two blocks away from where you're
at right now gently gun violence is
surging in Chicago once again two men
shot at a crowd during a block party 500
homicides so far but I didn't really
feel the gravity until it was in my
living room summer after my freshman
year in high school a young man got shot
across the street from my apartment
complex like a typical day we going to
the store to get some got in the car add
to the light shots rang golf I hear
gunshots and I look at my front window I
was shot fainted out of the vehicle we
ran through an alley and uh ran to the
back of apartment complex my back door
flies open and in runs Peeta he told me
his neck bleeding everywhere he was a
lot going through my head Oh a lot of
different emotions just asking me over
and over again can you help me can't
help me I've been shot and can you help
me lucky for him I was able to say it
hello good afternoon thank you all so
much for having us today like she said
I'm Martine you already know journey
we're with Ujima medics we want to teach
you all what to do if you're ever in a
situation where someone is injured by
being shot Regina medics is a black
health collective based in Chicago that
educates and trains people on how to
handle and apply first aid to urban help
case
so I'm going to say a statement if the
statement applies to you step up and
then back I live in a neighborhood where
there's been a shooting
[Music]
I've had a gunshot before
I know someone who's been shot
the ultimate goal is that we want to get
the wounded to an ambulance and into a
hospital as soon as possible
we just want to teach people how to
maximize that time the most so that way
instead of being filled with panic they
can instead being useful to a situation
and be empowered to help somebody that
they love or even somebody that they
don't even know and I'm gonna show you
first aid training we start off by going
over our first eight principles for the
first one you want read this for me
understand then we go into the actual
physical treatment of what to do with a
gunshot wound if you have a wound here
that's bright red strain blood and you
have a wound here that's losing blood
and it's dark and it's gargling you want
to do this one first how to talk to the
wounded how to treat them how to handle
them how to respect their bodily
autonomy and things like that you know
first aid right can I please help you
then after that we talk about what to do
when the ambulance gets there you're
gonna do the best you can with what you
know how to do because the model is
coming to take them to a higher level of
care there is a lot of gun and gang
violence that takes place in the city
but in addition to that there is a lack
of healthcare resources in these
communities that are affected the most
by gun violence not only well somebody
potentially have to travel a long
distance to get to a trauma center but
they will also have to potentially wait
15-20 minutes for an ambulance to get
there Damian was a young man that I
worked with and he was killed near the
University of Chicago hospital because
there was no level one adult trauma
center on the south side he passed away
in an ambulance ride on the way to
Northwestern Hospital which is 45
minutes across
town this huge hole was ripped in the
community that really created this
tension that for people we have to do
something so that began this long term
campaign for a University of Chicago
hospital to open a trauma center and
also began you medics I was literally
standing next to Damien's casket at his
viewing when the idea first came to me
I'm not gonna teach you how to do
anything crazy or out of your scope I'm
going to teach you how to use first aid
skills to save somebody's life okay
today the medics has trained probably
close to 1,500 and about seven trainers
have used their you medics training to
help be first responders in a gunshot
wound scenario you know we have no
illusions that we are taking steps to
solve any problem of gun violence first
aid is not a cure-all but changes the
way you look at life teaching people how
to care for their own body the bodies of
their friends actually impacts the
apathy that people feel about life when
you're growing up in a really violent
City
[Music]
so this was the first time that I met
Pete after he got out the hospital and
I'm basically just explaining to him how
important it is for his family to get
trained by you medics we trained his
entire family which is like maybe 20
people ranging from literally ages 3 to
70 after I faced Peters life
my role in new medics kind of went into
overdrive because then that just made me
feel like oh my god everybody needs to
have this training it kind of set a
standard for my life that was kind of
like you you have to show up because
look what happens when you do show up we
don't want to be doctors we don't teach
people how to be doctors or how to be
paramedics we want them to get in an
ambulance and get to the hospital as
soon as possible but how can we keep
people from dying how can we stop
burying our brothers and our mothers and
you know sisters it's not even simply
about getting the gunshot wound training
it's just the principle of how you're
gonna carry yourself now that you do
have this information and then it also
creates a level of community
accountability to say I got you like
you're my neighbor maybe we don't talk
every day and maybe we don't have
anything in common but if you're in need
I can help you out
[Music]
[Music]